[Music]
all right ladies eighty percent of us
are wearing the wrong
size bra and guess what it's not our
fault because when was the last time you
actually took the time to go in for a
professional bra fitting
we know it wasn't this past year was it
even the last decade
jeanette goldstein is the ceo of
jeanette bras she was an 80s actress you
might recognize her from aliens
she went to england and discovered
european bras and wanted to bring that
experience and quality back to the
states
now she's got several brick and mortar
stores in la and when the pandemic hit
she began
offering remote profitings you want to
create a really
safe space for a woman to come in
because this is intimate
clothing and it's an intimate experience
and you want to be with
someone who's not going to judge you
you're going to have a good time she's
going to meet your needs for both your
life
and your silhouette so in this way we've
just recreated the in-store experience
for
the virtual customer all right she also
says that her bra sizes go all the way
up to a
k-cup she says a good bra is like a good
pair of shoes and a nice pair of glasses
it's certainly an investment and ladies
you are worth it
she says after you get fitted she
promises you're gonna feel like a
million bucks
christian